j'ai une très mauvaise nouvelle votre
grand-père est mort je le connais même
pas ils veulent que je prenne l'avion
pour Rome demain soir pour mettre en
ordre ces affaires enfin je devrais pas
rester sauver mon mariage
il faut que tu commences à penser à toi
que j'ai bien atterri en Italie le
Colisée il est où
nous devons aller à l'enterrement
[Musique]
faisait mon grand-père dans
[Applaudissements]
la maison
[Musique]
c'est que tu deviennes ta nouvelle chef
de la famille bye bye
c'est un peu la folie à la maison de mon
fils vient d'entral à l'université mon
mari vient de me tromper
de lui
il nous faut quelqu'un qui est bien
équilibré
sans prétention et empathique tu viens
de dire que je suis empathique
les Roumanie toi
dans le film les parents oh oui
ok écoutez c'est vraiment difficile de
se libérer 3h30
tu as déjà trouvé ton italien il a
essayé de me tuer il a fait quoi
là les problèmes j'ai fait des bêtises
j'en ai marre de cette guerre ma famille
en a marre de cette guerre
[Musique]
non non
c'est une expression
[Musique]